The Eternals are one of Marvel's strangest
groups, and Thena is one of their most
fascinating members. A scholar, a warrior,
and an immortal, her life spans eons. We're
here to explain her entire story, from her ancient
origins to her unique relationship to Greek myth.
The Eternals are an immortal race of
super-beings, created through experiments on
early humans. Those experiments were conducted
by a group of ultra-powerful pseudo-deities known
as the Celestials, some of the first creatures
to ever exist in the Marvel universe.
The universe itself, called the First Firmament,
created a group of servants. This group soon split
into two: the Aspirants and the Celestials. The
Aspirants were loyal servants, who wished for
nothing more than to serve. The Celestials
deviated from the First Firmament's plan, wanting
to create lives of their own. This led to a civil
war between the inhabitants of the cosmos. In the
end, the Celestials triumphed. The First Firmament
and its Aspirants beat a hasty retreat into other
fragmented universes, leaving the Celestials to
tinker with the Marvel Universe as they pleased.
The Celestials landed on Earth eons ago and
set to experimenting upon early humanity.
What resulted were two offshoot groups:
The uniformly beautiful and enormously powerful
Eternals, and the dramatically mutated Deviants.
The Deviants' resentment of humanity led to an
adversarial relationship with Earth's inhabitants,
while their mutation allowed them to build
an advanced civilization in record time. In
short order, the Deviants built a vast and
cruel empire. At the same time, the Eternals
voted to remove themselves from humanity, building
isolated cities away from the rest of the world.
"We were instructed not to interfere with any
human conflicts unless Deviants are involved."
Both of these outcomes displeased the Celestials,
who flooded the Earth upon their return.
Thena, the daughter of Eternals' leader Zuras,
who was born as Azura around this time in the city
of Olympia. Though she's thousands of years old,
she's considered quite young compared
to many of her immortal brethren.
Jack Kirby created the Eternals with ancient Greek
myths in mind. Icarus became Ikaris. The god of
the forge Hephaestus became Phastos. The goddess
Circe became Sersi. To be clear, the Eternals are,
in most cases, not the gods they are mistaken
for. Most of those gods actually exist in the
Marvel universe. One exception is that Sersi
appears to really be the mythical Circe.
Generally speaking, though, the Eternals
are frequently confused for their Olympian
counterparts. The Eternal known as the
Forgotten One was often mistaken for Hercules,
who he's actually been buddies with
since ancient Greece. It follows,
then, that Thena, daughter
of an immortal named Zuras,
who led a city called Olympia, was mixed up
with the goddess Athena, daughter of Zeus.
Centuries ago, the Greek gods decided to put
down roots, only to find the Eternals already
established in Olympia. The two groups
met and noticed the striking resemblance.
A deal was struck in which the Eternals would act
as the Greek pantheon's representatives on Earth.
They would visit with humanity in the
gods' stead, leaving the deities to
their pocket dimension of Mount Olympus.
To seal the deal, Zuras decreed that his
daughter's name would change from Azura to
Thena. She came to be worshiped as Athena,
goddess of wisdom, war, and handicraft. She even
inspired the construction of the city of Athens.
The name stuck with her, and
she's continued to use it.
Thena might not be as much of a
dyed-in-the-wool pacifist as Phastos,
but she does view the fighting between the
Eternals and the Deviants to be essentially
pointless. That viewpoint only grew stronger
when she met and fell for a Deviant named Kro.
Kro and Thena met in ancient Babylon, where
Kro had an opportunity to slay Thena. He
refused. Love grew between the two, but Kro and
Thena knew to keep their relationship secret.
Their partnership is known to few, even as
it carried on for thousands of years. They
eventually had children together, after reigniting
their relationship during the Vietnam War.
Using her Eternal powers, Thena implanted
the resulting twin children in a human woman
to continue to keep the relationship secret.
They were born as Deborah and Donald Ritter,
seemingly ordinary humans. As Eternal-Deviant
hybrids, they were anything but.
Having to keep up appearances of fighting an
eternal war while secretly being in love with
your supposed enemy takes its toll. At times,
Kro's actions brought Thena and Kro into direct
conflict. Kro attacked New York City, leading
bands of Deviants through the city streets.
Zuras knew that he would have
to fight the Deviants yet again,
and sent his daughter to help
put down the Deviant uprising.
Though Thena was ultimately successful
in stopping the Deviant attack,
Kro still believed he accomplished
his goals. The Deviants
deeply hated the Celestials after years
of being treated as second-class beings.
They believed that their attacks would inspire a
widespread hatred of anything from outer space.
Feeling that he had done what he set out
to, Kro accepted a truce with the Eternals.
Leading the Eternals
When the Celestials came to Earth once again, the
leader of the Eternals made a shocking decision:
He attacked them. Zuras believed the Celestials
would destroy all of humanity if they found Earth
lacking. All of the world's semi-immortal beings,
including the Asgardians, worked to turn
back the Celestials for their own reasons.
When the Eternals formed the Uni-Mind,
a merging of their consciousnesses,
with Zuras at the center, it left the
leader particularly vulnerable. When
the Celestials struck the Uni-Mind
with a powerful bolt of energy,
Zuras was killed. Thena assumed command as
Prime Eternal, until she was forced to abdicate.
Ikaris, one of the most hot-headed Eternals,
never accepted Thena as the Prime Eternal.
And he carried quite a bit of sway in Olympia.
He repeatedly challenged Thena for her throne.
And though Ikaris was unsuccessful, Thena
struggled mightily with the responsibility
suddenly thrust upon her. She struggled with
the idea that the same fate that met her father
might await her and suffered beneath the weight
of being without her father for the first time.
It also didn't help that Kro had placed a
device on her that very subtly manipulated
her decision-making to favor the Deviants.
Thena was dedicated to keeping her people safe,
but her love for Kro, the influence of
his device, and her general anxiety came
to a disastrous head when she attacked
Ikaris to save Kro from certain death.
Ikaris took the opening, defeated
Thena, and took over as Prime Eternal.
Thena was one of the many Eternals who had
their memory wiped when the Eternal Sprite
manipulated reality. Totally ignorant of her
past and powers, Thena lived life as a human
researcher, working for Stark Enterprises. She
was knocked out of her mortal reverie by Ikaris,
who had broken Sprite's spell and needed
the help of the remaining Eternals to stop
another Celestial plot. While living as a human
named Ike Harris, Ikaris had been captured and
vaporized by Deviants. When his body reformed
in the Eternals' abandoned city of Olympia,
he realized that all of the Eternals were
suffering a similar case of memory loss.
"We need to find the others."
Thena and Ikaris traveled around the
world to find their former companions,
all living as everyday humans, and eventually
stopped the emergence of a sleeping Celestial
living underneath Los Angeles. After their
victory, Thena decided to live alongside the
human son she'd had in the interim, over
the objections of her fellow Eternals.
After millennia of life, Thena died alongside all
the other Eternals in a 2018 "Avengers" story.
A group known as the Dark Celestials
attacked Earth while the bodies of
regular Celestials began to rain down upon the
planet. Tony Stark traveled to Olympia to check
on the Celestials' most famous experiments,
and found the dead bodies of the Eternals.
In a dying monologue, Ikaris explained
that the Eternals weren't sent to Earth
to protect humanity: At the beginning
of the attack, they learned that they
were placed on Earth to cultivate humanity
as a viral weapon. Ikaris tells Iron Man,
"We are a lie, Tony Stark. We Eternals were great
fools. We weren't here to protect you. We were ...
to cultivate you. Your ... virulence. To them, to
the space gods, you ... are a useful pathogen."
This knowledge drove the Eternals mad. As Ikaris
lamented, they couldn't handle learning the truth,
and it destroyed them. Of course, this is
comics, so all the Eternals, including Thena,
came back to life in the 2021 "Eternals" series.
The Eternals are one of Marvel's more obscure
properties, and yet, an Eternals movie came to be,
meaning people around the world will
soon know all about Ikaris, Sersi,
and all the rest of the gang. That includes
Thena, who will be played by Angelina Jolie,
one of the most famous actresses on the planet.
"Hi."
"Hello."
Jolie has said she's committed to bringing
a realistic version of the immortal warrior
goddess to the silver screen. As she told USA
Today, she's explored everything from ballet
to swordsmanship in an effort to get the
graceful fighting of Thena down. She said:
"She's a warrior. I'm going to have to work
very hard to give the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the Thena they deserve."
Thena is a one-of-a-kind character who
deserves an actress of Jolie's caliber.
She might be soft-hearted
enough to fall for a Deviant,
but so too is she a legendary
scholar, warrior, and leader.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Marvel characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.